so um with my project basically it was
focusing on alertness and I think I like
the student the tired student who's
trying to stay awake in class or while
driving trying to stay awake or the
tired worker and how do you increase
alertness so I was looking at different
ways to increase alertness and there's
caffeine but caffeine is generally shown
to have negative side effects I think
that it's 500 milligrams taken daily can
increase heart rate blood pressure etc
so that's not necessarily like the ideal
solution for increasing awareness and
also it's known to be addictive and have
like diminishing returns so then I
looked at there's no feedback devices
and there's something called the peak
achievement trainer and it's a neuro
feedback device that supposedly works
very well at regulating alertness
increasing or decreasing it but that's
very expensive at several thousand
dollars only sold two licensed
professionals and it's not very
accessible it's a big device so after
like looking into the problem for a
while I came across an article about
active acupressure and it's in Eastern
theories it's been said maybe to
regulate learners acupressure is
basically been said to allies I said
it's a mainly for pain relief but
there's a lot of anecdotes of that I
acupressure can just regulate a whole
bunch of body rhythms so there wasn't
too much research on it as I dug deeper
I found one research article pretty
recently university of michigan and they
had subjects applier acupressure for one
day stimulation versus relaxation and
and subjects that applied acupressure to
or no stimulation areas so that they
were more alert during what was supposed
to be a boring lecture so that was a
positive sign for acupressure
wanted to take a more quantitative
analysis than a self rating system so i
developed we're known as enumeration
tasks and during these tasks um there's
a black screen and every 10 seconds 12
12 white squares flash on the monitor
and then after that they flash 4.3
seconds and after that there's a point
one second white screen just to clear
the image from the retina and this is
and if subjects would write down how
many squares they saw so this is to
determine what's known as like
magnocellular process saying it's um
basically the quick visual reflexes that
one has so that was I did that
enumeration task and then after 10 more
seconds and other set of white squares
of flash and this would repeat until all
combinations of from 1 to 12 white
squares flashed and I had 36 subjects
take this test and then I would score
the subjects based on how many the
outright put an X and columns where they
were incorrect on like a data
acquisition table and then I gave them a
total score so then this enabled me to
make three subject groups where I was
able to pair them so that each subject
group had the same initial scores in
terms of visual attention like the same
number of correct and also I was able to
pair them so there was like six miles 60
miles in each group so I had three
groups one that was intended to a by
stimulation acupressure one for
relaxation acupressure and one for now
acupressure and as I said the
stimulation acupressure or the
relaxation acupressure it's a slow firma
sashing with the these two fingers at a
90-degree angle to the target area for
three minutes and those five areas
that's 15 minutes each day it's not too
much of a time commitment but definitely
a time feeling with that I appreciate
from the subjects and after the subjects
did this for 14 days I give all the
subjects the same not the same another
enumeration test they all had the same
one but it was a different one and then
after another 14 days I gave them a
third enumeration jesc so during these
tasks in the stimulation acupressure
group the score is increased between day
0 and 14 there was a statistically
significant difference and then again
between fort de 1428 and it was the same
with the relaxation group there was a
statistically significant decrease
between days here on day 14 and then
another between day 14 and 28 so
this was good also there was the largest
difference between the first set days
around 14 then between day 14 28 and
this kind of makes sense because if
you're training with snow it's the
reticular activating system is which
believes to UM regulate one's attention
and it's located in the midbrain and
it's it's mainly in charge of regulating
which of the thousands of stimuli per
second we process so if you're listening
to this interview my voice will be one
of them see my image will be one of them
but there's thousands of things that you
don't even notice so like that's how
when like your name is called at a party
you might you might notice that because
you're training your reticular
activating system to to know this
particular stimuli as thousands of them
are being processed so the theory behind
this is that since the reticular
activating system controls what we can
process your training it to respond to
the acupressure so it will make sense
that there will be the largest response
initially and then that continued
response that with decrease also in
terms of like neuronal connections
you're going to make connections at
first rapidly and then connections in
the same location would occur less
rapidly but still continue to affair so
that's kind of why I had that trend so
then I analyzed the data Trent and I did
what's like known as regression analysis
to kind of see how visual tension scores
changed over time so they had a 28-day
analysis and I generally found that
because of that more more increase in
the first 14 days there was a general
natural logarithmic rate of increase in
the stimulation group and a natural
logarithmic rate of decrease in the
relaxation group so um so yeah that was
my results in terms of how acupressure
effects visual attention skills the type
of measurement of alertness and also how
it affects it over time so I was glad
that my hypothesis was supported in
terms of that and you know it has
positive implications for lots of groups
and so in the future I'd definitely be
interested in looking more into using it
for patients recovering from strokes for
example or or children for learning
to there's all types of applications
that that make it